[Music]
shoroma so nice to finally meet you what
pictures whoa you guys are holding hands
right now I love this you're so in love
we got a power through some tough
questions about the finale and then get
to the good stuff which is talking about
this amazing love you guys have so last
night last night was hard I have to say
as a fan it was one of the most intense
breakups between you and Peter that I've
ever seen on the show and a lot of fans
are watching it back and saying it
seemed like your feelings at that time
were even stronger for Peter than they
were for Brian how do you respond to
those fans I mean I think it's it's hard
when people say that because it's like
you think you know but you have no idea
but you really don't and the emotion
that you see coming for me is that there
was a lot of push and pull and to be
honest with you I felt a little bit of
manipulation in there and I it triggered
past emotions from like my past
relationships you hear me talk about my
five-year relationship a lot the lack of
commitment you telling me that you
wanted this future with me but you
didn't want to take the actions to have
it like that's what triggered my like
this those emotions in me what is
manipulation means he's manipulating you
I felt like there was a lot of push and
pull felt like you he was giving me just
enough to keep me and string me along
rather than being forthcoming with
everything and the thing is is when I
walked in I knew what I was going to do
and I still kept getting that push in
that pool and so it was it was hard like
it was hard and there's the same time
you know like I've never been good at
goodbyes like heartbreaks are hard and I
don't like hurting someone's feelings so
like you see that so when you walked in
you knew you were going to break up with
Peter that I did and how hard was that
for you to watch because at the end made
they exchanged I love yous to each other
at one point yeah I mean I think there's
a difference between I love you and I'm
in love with you and Rachel actually
told me she was in love with me back in
the fantasy suite
so I was a bit of context out and it was
a stark contrast in that we never had
any issues I never need her to cry for
me to validate her feelings for me you
know I it was it was smooth sailing from
night one as you saw and you know just
to wash that over with
Peter it was just frustrating to see her
go through that exactly what she was
talking about that push-pull you know
here you have somebody that Amy that was
totally forthright from day one
totally invested totally committed and
then on the other end you have this
person who's you know back and forth
wishy-washy doesn't really know what he
wants and you know it's tough to watch
as a man can I ask you did you say I'm
in love with you to Peter in the fantasy
suite
no I it was very important for me I've
been very upfront you know I felt
strongly for my last floor and I loved
each of them in a different way and with
Brian he's the only one that I said I
was in love with too
and I really wanted to reserve that
language that feeling for one person and
that was Brian for me yeah that's his
spoiler alert thank you my a lot of
evidence well and honest um you guys
have used the word frustrating a lot why
was it so frustrating to see Peter last
night were there things that you wanted
him to say that he didn't say why was it
so frustrating he even said he felt
attacked yeah I questioned him on how he
felt attacked and I don't know where
that was coming from and he couldn't
really explain that either so I don't
know if he just threw that word out
there but he couldn't back it up
frustrating for me I think to go back
and be in that same place I'm three
months removed from that and to watch it
over and over again and then for him to
come out and like you really couldn't
explain it I don't know it's frustrating
to me and then it's also frustrating to
hear so many people like back that
behavior up that's what's frustrating to
me like they don't see the essence of
Brian and the love story that we have
and they're still fixated on the lack of
commitment that Peter was showing I
don't I don't get it
fans were saying that you're being a
little too hard on Peter what do you
have to say to those people I mean Peter
Jim dude over on I feel like I wasn't
hard I was direct I think I knew what I
was going to say I was watching it live
with the audience for the first time so
watching it I knew what I wanted to say
to him and I was I didn't hold back like
I didn't think I was hard on him I was
very direct well you were very direct
about saying I do not
you should do this show you should not
be the bachelor I guess is what you're
saying right you don't think leader
should be the bad shot well I'm not
talking about bachelor I just you know
you have to take a leap of faith and I
struggled with that and I thought that
Peter and I had that similarity I
struggle with that on Nick season but I
eventually let myself go because I knew
what I wanted for myself and I knew that
coming into my season I had to take that
same leap of faith and being in this
process in this journey that's what it's
about you take the leap of faith he
wasn't willing to do that
and so it's not that Peters not a great
guy he's not sincere and genuine it's
just he takes his own pace and that pace
doesn't fit in this experience and
that's what I was saying so do you think
Peter should be the bachelor I said Alex
should be the next better I've always
resent that yeah yeah where you told me
you like I don't any mind final for
being The Bachelor yeah yeah I
definitely do not okay and is that just
because you don't think Peter is in for
the process or do you think he's angling
to be the bachelor I have no idea like I
have no idea what his motives are okay
I'm all right well I'm getting the wrap
sign for you guys already so let me just
make sure I don't have any other super
important questions for you and
hopefully I can ask you see fun ones
before you wrap
do you think I guess last question about
Peter do you think he was a different
person last night than the guy that you
got to know on the show I think you saw
the essence of Peter in that breakup I
think people saw a different side of him
they still aren't willing to accept I
mean the man told me I was going to have
a mediocre life if I wasn't with him and
then apologized about it you know and
I'm not I'm having an amazing life like
this last we must have been absolutely
amazing okay did that so good to tell
mine wasn't my best life Oh 100%
it felt great all right we're just
matched you guys really quick fun
questions about you because I won't talk
about you too
so let's show off that ring that ring
one is the three carats here yesterday
oh he did good go good I have to say for
myself you did good convert where I feel
were a little bit lower here but that
one's bigger that one's bigger right and
how would you see that you guys's
relationship is different today now
versus that great night when you
proposed I think we're just so mature
you know our communication is off the
charts our love for each other's
off-the-charts I think we're just both
very individually we're mentally strong
so as far as all the negative forces on
the outside I think at this stage in our
lives I think we're the best equipped to
handle those things and how are you guys
going to make sure that you don't fall
into some of those pitfalls of you're on
the show it's a rush Fame here it's a
lot going on how are you going to keep
this relationship strong through all
that communication with a key yeah
throughout the process throughout the
three months that we finish the show
FaceTime calls several times a day I
mean we we don't stop talking each other
so I think yeah we and we bring up you
know all the tough topics everything and
also the light topics but you know we
discuss everything when we leave we put
everything out on the table very last
question you said that you had talked
about maybe la Dallas Miami is living in
LA is that maybe a thought of Dancing
with the Stars factoring into you guys
was like that I haven't even begun
think about dance okay where's is trying
to like be together lots ago yeah any
timeline and when you move in know where
you have no idea which is attainable
again okay very quickly I have presents
for you I feel like Jerome you know you
found your home with Jerome so for you
Jerome sweet Jerome is revealed
but they're also missing Rome is your
home sweet home and you get to have
Jerome at lab she's got the little
v-neck I mean will there be a little one
for a kid if you got kids in baby
we do want cousin for she wants a fourth
to be an axe and I want the phone three
[Music]
you